[موسيقى]
خبر هام للمعلمين على الانترنت جوجل معرضه
لتفكيك بسبب دعوه مكافحه احتكار مرفوعه من
وزاره العدل الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
جوجل فاصله وحدتها التي تلعب دور الوسيط
في سوق الاعلانات على شبكه الانترنت لماذا
جوجل متهمه بالاحتكار ببساطه
الاول هو سر الاعلانات وهو السيرفر الذي
يستخدمه اصحاب المواقع الالكترونيه
[موسيقى]
31 مليار و700 مليون دولار في 20 21 جوجل
بنات امبراطوريتها الاعلانيه على مدى
عقدين من الزمان وهي الان من السيطره الى
منازع على سوق الاعلانات الرقميه التي تصل
الى 500 مليار دولار تفكيك جوجل ليس بهذه
السهوله فتقيم وحده الاعلانات يصل
بالتاكيد الى عشرات مليارات الدولارات ومن
الصعب جدا ايجاد شركه قادره على شراءها
والمشكله الاخرى ان شركات التكنولوجيا
الكبرى قد لا تكون مستوفيا لشروط الشراء
لان الشركات مثل مايكروسوفت مثلا ستواجه
نفس مشكلتي مكافحه الاحتكار في حاله
التقدمها ولذلك قد يكون الخيار الافضل
خاصه وحده الاعلانات في جوجل وترحها في
السوق لتصبح شركه اخرى مستقله في نادي
عمالقه التكنولوجيا هل تعتقد ان خطوه كهذه
ستكون افضل سوق الاعلانات رقميه